The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: Good.
So before we start, do
you have any questions
on what we did before?
OK.
So we have discussed
that a black hole can be
considered as a similar object.
And that, actually, black
holes obey the standard law
of thermodynamics.
And now we also mentioned
that it's a natural question
to ask whether the
black hole should we
be considered as an ordinary
quantum mechanical object.
And so this is related to the
issue of information paradox.
So by this regard, this
information paradox,
which I think now has a
very good-- in principle
has a reasonable resolution,
which we will talk about later.
But if we do treat the black
hole as an ordinary quantum
mechanical object,
then they actually
are very important implications.
So one implication is called
the holographic principle.
So, the holographic principle
by itself is, in some sense,
a rather heuristic
concept at the moment.
And I will also only give you
a very heuristic discussion.
And it's possible to make it
a little bit more rigorous.
But we will do it a
rather heuristic level,
just to give you a
feeling that there
is something profound going
on in quantum gravity because
of black holes.
So let's consider an
isolated system of mass.
Say E and, say,
entropy as zero, say
in asymptotic flat spacetime.
And then we also denote A
as the area of the smallest
sphere that closes the system.
And also let me
introduce-- let MA
be the mass of the black hole,
of the same horizon area.
Yes.
Black hole with
horizon area A. OK?
So in GR, anything which
is sufficiently massive
will eventually collapse
to form a black hole.
Because of that-- so we must
have E is smaller than MA,
So we must have E--
so whatever energy
you can put in this
region surrounded by area
A must be smaller than
the mass of a black hole
which you can put
in that region.
OK?
Because otherwise,
if we have more mass,
then it will already
be a black hole.
AUDIENCE: Should that be equal?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Should it be equal?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Say equal.
So now let's suppose
E is smaller than MA.
So we can now-- so suppose
E is smaller than MA
and now we can add
this amount of energy,
say MA minus E amount of
energy, to the system.
OK.
Suppose we can do
that and keep A fixed.
And then this will
reach a black hole mass.
Then the final system
will have a black hole,
will have the
energy given by MA.
And that object
must be a black hole
because that's the black hole
with the same horizon area.
Because this process
also tells you
that the black hole entropy
must be greater than the S0,
the initial entropy of this
system, plus the S prime-- S
prime is the entropy
of added energy.
OK.
So just because of the
second law of thermodynamics,
your entropy should
not decrease.
So the final-- so you add this
amount of energy so to MA,
so then you will precisely form
a black hole over the mass MA,
and with the horizon area A.
But this black hole entropy
should be greater than its
zero plus the entropy you
added from the second
law of thermodynamics.
So then that means your
initial entropy must be smaller
than the black hole entropy.
Must be smaller than A
divided by 4 h bar G newton.
So this argument tells you
that the maximal entropy
inside a region bounded
by area A is given by--
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So will keeping
A fixed add entropy
to the system?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in that case,
why don't we have such a term?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: So you said
we want to keep A fixed.
HONG LIU: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Will that add
extra entropy to the system?
HONG LIU: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So according to the
second law of thermodynamics,
why will we claim that
the entropy of the hole
is greater than or
equal than S0 plus S--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
OK.
It's add the energy.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Because it-- Yeah.
This is the energy
of added energy.
AUDIENCE: How about
the extra energy
that might be introduced
by keeping A fixed?
Because it's not--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Whatever it is.
Suppose you can keep A fixed.
Then whatever things
you added to that--
that total entropy-- must be
smaller than the [INAUDIBLE]
because black hole
is the final state.
AUDIENCE: You said it's an
isolated system, so with that,
how can you make
sure that A is fixed?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Why is an
isolated system--
HONG LIU: Oh.
Yeah.
I'm just saying, we are
doing a thought experiment.
Imagine you can do this
by keeping A fixed.
Yeah, just say you just put
stuff in into this region.
So that stuff does not come out.
Yeah, you just have some
region A. Let me do it here.
You have some region A. And
there is a mass inside here.
There's some energy
stuff inside here.
So this is region A. And then
you just keep putting stuff in.
Just keep putting stuff
in so that those things
don't come out A-- don't
come out of this region.
That's what this means.
AUDIENCE: Then A is not
the smallest sphere?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Then A is not
the smallest sphere?
HONG LIU: A is what?
AUDIENCE: Not the
smallest sphere
that can enclose the system.
So it's not--
HONG LIU: No.
A is not the smallest
sphere in the system.
A is just-- maybe I
should call this-- A is
the area of a sphere.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Thanks.
So just enough A to be a sphere
that encloses the system.
Yeah.
Should not put the smallest
sphere for some reason.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
A should not be the smallest.
Just-- A is any sphere.
Just some sphere which
encloses the region.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So it seems that
this argument implicitly
assumed that in
order to add entropy,
that sort of corresponds to
adding some amount of energy.
But is it possible to
add entropy to the system
without adding
energy to the system?
HONG LIU: Oh, you can.
You can.
They just make it even more.
Whatever it is, this
is the final state.
So the base
assumption of this is
that if you can put stuff
inside this region, whatever
is inside, the sum is,
the maximal stuff you
can put inside the region is
a black hole with the horizon
area.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
guess what I'm confused
about is that it seems, that--
I certainly believe when
you said, you can't
have a certain amount
of energy in an area.
But I'm not sure
why you can't have
a certain amount of
entropy in an area
if energy and entropy are not--
HONG LIU: No.
We're not making
that assumption.
The entropy is just a
consequence of that.
This is the final state entropy.
And the final state
entropy is always
larger than the entropy
of your initial state.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Sure.
Fine.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah.
Entropy is derived.
This equation is not assumption.
It's derived.
AUDIENCE: Fine.
OK.
HONG LIU: The assumption
is that the black hole
is the maximal-- is the
most massive object you
can put inside this region.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I see.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But you can't
have a less massive object
with more than that entropy.
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: You can't have a less
massive object with entropy
that is more than that value.
Inside the same region.
HONG LIU: This is
ruled out by this--
once you get this equation, then
you don't ask about the mass.
It just-- any entropy must
be smaller than this value.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: How do we keep track
of what the area of [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Right.
So that's why I say this is a
little bit heuristic argument.
And that's why I say this
is a heuristic argument.
Yeah.
Yeah, indeed, you have
to be a little bit more
careful about that.
Yeah but say if you-- the
key thing is about the area.
And then this other
one cautions one maybe
to have to think about it.
When you include the
quantum corrections
et cetera-- the back
reaction, et cetera.
But the key thing is the
area of the black hole.
It must be proportionate
to the area.
AUDIENCE: Well.
[INAUDIBLE] for some
function that the area
of the horizon with the black
hole is only based on the mass.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah.
So let me say again, there's
two natures of this argument.
The first nature
of the argument is,
the maximal energy you
can put inside the region
is a black hole whose
horizon area is given
by the area of this region.
AUDIENCE: This is an assumption.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
This is assumption.
Yeah, because we
know, in the GR,
any sufficiently
massive thing will
collapse to form a black hole.
AUDIENCE: Mmhmm.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
And if you have a more
mass, then the horizon area
would be outside.
And then you will be
outside this area.
You can no longer
keep this A fixed.
So that's the first assumption.
So we said that assumption--
that assumption then
just follows from the second
law of thermodynamics.
Because this is
whatever-- the entropy
of the matter inside-- then this
is whatever the initial entropy
of the energy-- you
need to put it in
to make it into a black hole.
And then that must be
smaller than the entropy
of the final state, which is
the entropy of the black hole.
AUDIENCE: But my question
is that by keeping A fixed,
you might introduce extra
entropy into the system.
HONG LIU: Hm?
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
As far as the black hole
is the final entropy state.
What you're saying
is that there might
be some other things here.
It's fine.
That does not change
the direction of this--
AUDIENCE: The entropy
might be negative.
I'm not sure-- just--
HONG LIU: No.
No.
Whatever it is--
this is my initial.
So that's why this is
an inequality here.
This is not the equality.
Inequality.
And we're just using the
second law of thermodynamics.
This is your initial
state entropy.
This is my final state entropy.
This must be greater than that.
We're not asking the
specific process.
Yeah.
Just, the final state must be
greater than the initial state.
Good?
OK.
So now let's see what we can
try to go a little bit further
from here.
So now let's recall.
So now we really
treat the black hole
as a quantum statistical object.
So now recall the
definition of entropy
in quantum statistical physics.
OK.
So if you say I
have some system,
and the state of that system
is described by some density
operator, or density
matrix, and then
that the entropy of that system
is just given by this formula.
In particular, for a system with
n-dimensional Hilbert space.
OK.
So this is the
n-dimensional Hilbert space.
This is a dimension
of the Hilbert space.
Let S max is log
N. So the maximum
possible entropy you
can have is log N.
OK.
Is this fact familiar to you?
So you can convince
yourself the maximal entropy
is realized when role is just
given by 1/n times the identity
matrix.
And so is the density matrix
which has low information.
Because every state
plays the same role.
And this state-- then
you can plug in here
and give your log N.
And the maximum entropy
means you have
minimal information.
And that is the state
with minimal information.
And you can also just prove
yourself using some algebra.
But this is the physical
argument for this.
So now, if you compare
with these two formula,
then we can draw
a conclusion, is
that-- so let me
add a word called
effective-- effective
dimension-- of the Hilbert
space for a system
inside a region of area A
is bounded by log N must
be smaller than A h bar GN.
So that tells you-- so
whatever you can put inside
of this region of area A,
that's the maximal entropy you
can have.
So if you have N
degrees of freedom,
then the maximal
entropy you can have
for this N degrees
of freedom is log N.
Then that tells you that log
N must be smaller than this.
OK?
Smaller or equal to that.
And so let me
write this in terms
of the-- so this
can also, 4 h bar N
is also Planck length square.
So it's also four times
a Planck length square.
AUDIENCE: So for this
part, really Hilbert space
really can be even infinite.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
And let me say that.
So that's why we
need "effective."
So now let me make some remarks.
Let me make some remarks.
So zero remarks.
It says, for system of n spins
say, n spins half particle--
so when I say spins, I always
means spins half-- then
the dimension of the Hilbert
space is 2 to the power n.
Just to remind you.
But the dimension of h-- the
Hilbert space-- so normally I
just group h to denote
the Hilbert space--
for a single
harmonic oscillator.
So the simplest system is spin.
Then the next simplest
system is essentially
a harmonic oscillator.
And even for a single
harmonic oscillator, then
the dimension of h is infinite.
OK.
And then you ask what
I'm talking about here.
Because here I say
the Hilbert space
should be smaller than that.
But.
So even though, even for a
single harmonic oscillator
the Hilbert space is infinite,
but for a quantum mechanical
system, for a quantum system
with a finite number of degrees
of freedom-- by finite
number of degrees of freedom,
for example, you can
interpret this, for example,
as a finite number of
harmonic oscillators, OK--
the dimension of
the Hilbert space
below some finite energy scale.
Energy is always finite.
It's always finite.
And so that's why I use
the word "effective" there.
And because normally we all
consider the finite energy,
because the system will
have finite energy,
and then you have,
effectively, a finite dimension
of Hilbert space.
OK?
So this equation
is not that crazy.
So I mean typical-- so actually,
in typical physical systems,
even for harmonic oscillators,
both for spin or harmonic
oscillators, essentially,
number of degrees of freedom
is of all the log N. Yeah,
N is the effective dimension
of your Hilbert space.
Yeah, this is obvious
from the spin.
This is also obvious if you
have a harmonic oscillator.
So if each harmonic oscillator
is finitely excited.
And again, roughly the
log N is the number
of harmonic oscillators.
So because of this we can
also write this equation
as the number of degrees of
freedom of any quantum gravity
system inside the
region A can be--
should be smaller
than-- should be bounded
by the area of that region.
So this bond is
certainly violated
in non-gravitational
systems because
systems whose number
of degrees of freedom
and thus, the log
N, the log of your dimension
of your Hilbert space,
is proportional to the
volume rather than area.
So when the reading
is big enough,
then you are guaranteed
to violate this bound.
Because, of course, the volume
grows faster than the area
if you have a sufficiently
larger region.
So for example, consider
just a lattice of spins--
so a three dimensional lattice
of spins-- of lattice spacing
a-- say of lattice spacing a--
then the total number of spins
that is given by volume
divided by A cubed.
So this is essentially the
number of degrees of freedom.
And then this is given by A,
the area, divided by a squared,
times L divided by a.
And this can be
much, much greater
than a divided by Planck
square, Planck length square,
for L sufficiently large.
They are large enough.
So if you have a long
gravitational system,
then this boundary can
be easily violated.
In particular, this
equation can also
be violated because the
dimension of the Hilbert space
that in this case would
2 to the power a cubed,
and similarly-- so a-- so
the maximal entropy would be,
say, v divided by a cubed log
2, because it's a spin 2 system,
spin half system.
So this can be larger than
the entropy of a black hole.
So it's key that we can see
the gravitational systems.
Only in gravitational
systems you
have this remarkable
feature that if you-- things
will collapse.
Things will collapse.
And then you will
have this upper limit
provided by the black hole.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So in the real
world, every system's
a gravitational system.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So this is
just-- in some sense,
this is not actually
correct in the real world.
HONG LIU: Yeah, but you need
this L to be not enough.
AUDIENCE: I see.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, right.
In the real world, this bound
has to be obeyed by systems.
So does that put some bounds
on QFT UV completions?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: So, in the
real world this bound
has to be obeyed by everything.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So does that put
some kind of restrictions
on QFT UV completion?
Because we usually say
it's infinite density
of degrees of freedom.
HONG LIU: No, because
UV completion of QFT
is provided by gravity.
AUDIENCE: For any QFT.
I just mean, like,
a scalar fuel.
HONG LIU: Then that's not
the theory of gravity.
AUDIENCE: Right, but
if you have a scalar
fuel in space time, which has GR
in it, is otherwise like, flat?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Then the GR-- then the gravity
will provide the UV completion
on that scalar field.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Right.
I was going to say something
else, but I forgot.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: Haha.
AUDIENCE: What about the
ones that are to be complete?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: What
about the theories
that are to be complete
at least, formally?
HONG LIU: Uh.
Sorry, say it again?
AUDIENCE: The QFTs that
are to be complete.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
They are limited by gravity.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
The gravity will still
provide something.
Because a QFT have infinite
number of degrees of freedom.
Yeah.
So as an example of
this, for example you
can think of a classroom,
say, full of photons,
and then you can
calculate entropy.
Again, that entropy will be
proportional to the volume.
So if you make the
classroom big enough,
then that will
violate this bound.
But it's a simple exercise
for you to do yourself,
that if you put the classroom
at a finite temperature
of photons, then when
the room is big enough,
there's always a
radius that will
collapse to form a black hole
before this bound is violated.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: OK.
I think maybe I have this
formula in the p-set.
I forgot whether
I have it or not.
Yeah, you can do this
simple exercise yourself.
Yeah just imagine you
have a box of photons
at any non-zero
temperature t, and then
when you put the box big enough,
then at a certain point then
this whole box of photons will
collapse to form a black hole.
And that's within to make
this bound to be satisfied.
So what this means--
that if you have gravity,
the quantum gravity leads to
a huge reduction of number
of degrees of freedom.
It's really bounded
by your area.
AUDIENCE: Now, in previous
argument [INAUDIBLE],
you have a conformal
field theory.
And so this other [INAUDIBLE] we
don't need to have [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: No.
Yeah.
As I was answering Pavel before,
if you have a conformal field
theory just by itself,
then there's no bound.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
HONG LIU: Then there's no bound.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
HONG LIU: But if you couple
this conformal field theory
to gravity, then at
sufficiently high energy,
and then the degrees of freedom
of this conformal field theory
must be reduced.
AUDIENCE: No, but, if you just
had a conformal field theory,
then there's no bound.
HONG LIU: No bound.
Yeah.
Yeah, but you can
ask what happens
if we couple a conformal
field theory to gravity.
Not even conformal field theory,
just any quantum field theory,
because any quantum field
theory has an infinite number
of degrees of freedom, and the
number of degrees of freedom
is also proportional
to the volume.
And if you couple it to
gravity, then this reduction
must happen.
This reduction must happen.
OK.
So now if we take a
small leap of faith--
so we already have taken
some leaps of faith,
but let's take one more
stab, or leap of faith-- then
you can formulate
something called
the holographic principle.
So given that the
number of degrees
of freedom inside the region
is always bounded by the area,
and this area actually
has a very nice way,
it's area in the unit
of a Planck lens--
it looks like we have a minimal
lens-- minimal area which
is a Planck's square
lens-- and just
the area divided by that gives
you the total number of degrees
of freedom.
OK.
So if you try to extrapolate
a little bit further,
then we have the so-called
holographic principle.
It says, in quantum gravity,
a region of boundary area A
can be fully described--
can be fully described
by no more than--
so essentially it's
just A h bar hN equals
A [INAUDIBLE] squared
degrees freedom.
In other words, one degree
of freedom per Planck area.
So this is a rough formulation
of the holographic principle.
So what we just said--
it just highlights
a point we made earlier--
is that even though naively,
from dimensional analysis,
that the quantum gravity
is only operating, say,
at the Planck scale.
Say, at the Planck mass
or [INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
And we see that the
black hole actually
brings the quantum
gravity really
need to macroscopic level.
OK.
Because this is, really
macroscopic statement
can apply to regions
of arbitrary sides.
But somehow, they are limited by
constraints of quantum gravity.
OK.
So this is a remarkable
manifestation
of the quantum effect.
Any questions on this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's
so special about
the dimensional differences?
HONG LIU: Oh.
Yeah.
This we can generalize
to any dimension.
There's always
core dimension two.
So if you live in
five dimensions,
then becomes three
dimensions-- yeah,
it's always co-dimension
y in the spatial region.
Because the black hole--
just area of the black hole
is always co-dimension
y in terms of spatial.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, can't it
be just [INAUDIBLE] sphere,
and then it's [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Yeah.
10-dimensional
space, then naively,
this would be constrained by
eight-dimensional surface.
Yeah.
Yeah, just, no matter
what dimension,
it's always constrained by
the surface, not constrained
by the volume.
No matter what dimension.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: I just have a
question about [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So it seems like
we are constraining a system
[INAUDIBLE] theory that its
number of states for a given
energy must grow slower somehow
because we must be lower
than some finite energy.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The number of
[INAUDIBLE] must be below
certain--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Just say-- essentially,
what we said earlier,
is if you are in the
theory of quantum gravity,
there's a cutoff on the
maximal energy you can have.
And there's a cutoff also on
the maximal energy you can have,
because otherwise you
form a black hole,
and then that cutoff
will translate
into the state of the
[INAUDIBLE] of entropy
and into the number
of degrees of freedom.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I mean--
HONG LIU: Because much
easier-- yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
for example, we
have-- first we start
with a simple series,
and maybe, for example, we add,
for example, standard model,
then we add super symmetry,
then-- energy spectrum-- the
limiting energy that is there,
but the number of Hilbert space
state is more, and we can
keep doing things like that.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But we can't.
Because it must be
below these values.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
But you see, there is something
about the volume here.
You have to talk about
within some region.
Of course, abstractly, you
can put some degree-- yeah,
maybe I'm not getting
your question.
AUDIENCE: How do
you say-- naively,
we think, we can
just, for example,
say if the energy boundary
is here, and below this,
how many states we could have?
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
This is not the
direction in terms
of the entropy-- energy bound.
This is, in the end, is the
bound on the [INAUDIBLE]
degrees of freedom you
can put inside a region.
If you put too many degrees
of freedom inside the region,
then you need to
enlarge the region.
Yeah.
Just say, look at the
number of degrees of freedom
is incompatible.
Something like that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I have a question
regarding [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I still
don't understand.
Shouldn't an isolated
system mean also included
the machinery to
do these things?
HONG LIU: No.
I'm just saying you start
with the isolated system.
Then you can add something
to that isolated system.
AUDIENCE: What about
if we take matters out
of the black hole,
these [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: That thing,
that isolated system,
does not have to
be a black hole.
It can be anything.
It just can be anything.
AUDIENCE: So if we instead
of putting energy inside,
we take energy out,
entropy will decrease?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Just take entropy out.
Yeah.
Then this bound will
be even more satisfied.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I have
a question there,
that the degree of freedom--
I mean log of the degree
of freedom--
HONG LIU: No.
No.
N is the dimension
of the Hilbert space.
That's why I called it N, here.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
HONG LIU: N, the dimension
of the Hilbert space.
AUDIENCE: But-- the
degree of freedom is--
HONG LIU: Typically, the
number of-- the dimension
of the Hilbert space is
exponential of the lambda
of degrees of freedom.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
OK.
HONG LIU: Just look at here.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
I see.
HONG LIU: Just look at here.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
OK.
AUDIENCE: If we have a
quantum field theory,
it has a certain
vacuum energy, right?
And then if you now consider
that to be the vacuum energy
and you expand it at some
point, it will actually
collapse into a black hole?
So if you take the
vacuum energy to be
that predicted by QFT,
then for the universe,
it would not work.
Even theoretically-- I know
the [INAUDIBLE] constant
is like 120 orders less, but.
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's a little
bit tricky because-- yeah,
so the vacuum energy
will make it into, say,
depending on whether the vacuum
energy is positive or negative
will make it into de Sitter,
anti-de Sitter, then, yeah,
then you try to see whether--
it depends on details.
AUDIENCE: But if
you go big enough,
it's going to collapse, or--
HONG LIU: No.
Not necessarily.
I'm just saying that
you have to formulate
a little bit differently.
You're talking about
a particular state
of certain energy to
couple to gravity,
then you just take that
state coupled to gravity
to see what you get.
Yeah, then ask
questions from there.
Yeah.
Good.
So now let's move
to a new topic.
Still, it's in the preparation
to go to the duality
but we need a lot of pieces
of important intuition
in order to fully
appreciate the duality.
And in this piece of
intuition is Large N theories.
And let me call it
Large N matrix theories.
So now we try to look at the
hint for holographic duality
from the field theory side.
So so far, we have been talking
about the hint for holographic
from the gravity
side, and now we
look at it from the
field theory side,
to see, actually from
there also some hints
to relate a long gravity
system to a gravity system.
OK.
So let's start with QCD.
So QCD is a SU(3) gauge
theory plus quarks.
So let me just write
down it's Lagrangian.
So this F describes the
gluon fields and this side
describes the quarks.
OK.
So this F is built out of
the standard partial mu
A mu minus partial mu
A mu minus A mu A mu,
and A mu-- each gauge field
is a 3 by 3 Hermitian matrix.
So these are 3 times
3 Hermitian matrix.
So this is using
the matrix notation,
so F is also a matrix.
So there's a trace here.
OK.
Hermitian matrix.
And then the T to a is
just generators of SU(3).
So it doesn't matter
if you don't know QCD.
It doesn't matter if you
have not seen QCD before.
The only thing that
matters is just
to remember that QCD is
a series of matrices.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: QCD is a series
of 3 by 3 matrices.
OK.
So the gluon field
is 3 by 3 matrices.
It's described by matrices.
So of course, one of
the remarkable things
about the QCD-- what's the most
remarkable thing about QCD,
do you know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah.
That's one.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: And what other
remarkable thing about the QCD?
AUDIENCE: Soft coupling?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Soft coupling.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
It's related to that.
AUDIENCE: Confinement, then.
HONG LIU: Yeah, confinement,
it's also related to that.
It's just-- yeah, one of
the most remarkable things
about QCD is it's
still not solvable.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: And the
reason it's not solvable
is because when you've
got low energies,
the coupling becomes
strong, then we
don't know how to deal with it.
OK.
So we still don't know
how to calculate it
from first principle.
Of course, we can put
it on the computer,
but just from the-- in terms
of theoretical understanding,
it's hard.
So in 1974-- so this is an old
problem-- so starting in 1974--
starting in 1971, people
already tried to solve it.
So in 1974-- so the big
problem with of this thing
is that in quantum field theory,
normally we do expansions.
OK.
Say we find some starting
point, so in physics, that's
what we always do.
We find the starting
point, which can be solved.
Then we expand around
that starting point.
And that starting point
is often a free theory.
And then it may expand
upon the free theory.
So the difficult thing about
this theory is at first,
it's hard, when you go
to low energies-- first
it's hard to find
the starting point.
And the second is that's
there's nothing to expand.
Because there's no
small parameters.
OK.
There's no small parameters.
When you need to
expand, you will always
need a small parameter.
So in 1974, t' Hooft came
up with a very nice idea.
He said, this is SU(3).
He said, let's just
think of taking
the number of colors, which is
N equal to 3, as a parameter.
So even though you
realize, he said, there's
only three types of colors.
But let's imagine we treat
it as a free parameter.
OK.
So this just implies, say
you promote the gauge field
by M matrices.
And by N Hermitian matrices.
OK.
He said, let's just treat this
in terms of N by N matrices.
And then this let's consider
that N goes to infinity limit.
So let's consider that N
goes to infinity limit.
So he reasoned, if N
goes to infinity limit,
it's sufficiently simple, then
maybe we can solve that limit.
And then do 1/N expansion.
1/N is a small parameter.
Then we can treat 1/N
as a small parameter
and then do one
of the expansions.
OK.
So that's the rough idea.
And then you get a
small parameter of 1/N.
So in real life,
N will be three.
So 1/3.
It's not very small, but
it's at least smaller than 1.
OK, so, this turns out
to be a genius idea.
Turns out to be a genius idea.
But unfortunately, QCD still
cannot be solved this way.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: But
there's a surprise.
But there's a surprise.
So, still, QCD, you
cannot solve this way.
Even N going to infinity limit
turned out to be too hard.
But there's a surprise.
It turns out this 1/N expansion
gives you a string theory.
OK.
So I will now explain this, OK.
I will now explain this.
So there's a byproduct
of his large N expansion.
You said, you find that
this actually-- such a gauge
theory actually sticks
with real string theory.
So the key is that these
fields are matrices.
OK.
So the key reason
this emerges is
because we are working with
a field, which are matrices.
So to illustrate this,
I will not do the QCD.
It's a little bit complicated.
I will just do a simple
scalar field theory.
OK.
So I will just do a
simple scalar field theory
as an illustration.
So let's consider
the following theory.
OK.
So this g is still
coupling constants.
But what we do is actually
convenient to put it
in the front.
Of course you can rescale
it-- you can rescale it,
you put it here, which
is the normal place.
But I put it in the front.
Just like what we
normally do also for QCD.
So this g is coupling constant
which we put in the front.
And then each phi,
again, I take it to be
N by N in the Hermitian matrix.
Phi x, each one
is a matrix a, b.
So I have two index.
So this N by N Hermitian matrix.
Yeah.
N by N, Hermitian matrix.
So which means that phi a b,
equal to star equal to phi b a.
OK.
So there's a difference between
the upper and lower indices.
OK.
So I can write it more explicit
in terms of components.
So just to give you,
in case some of you
are not familiar with this kind
of matrix kind of field theory,
so let me just also write
it in terms of components.
So writing in terms
of components,
it's 1/2 partial mu, phi
a b, then partial mu,
phi b a, then plus 1/4 phi a b,
phi b c, phi c a, no-- phi c d,
phi d a.
OK.
So this is the just having
writing down explicitly
using components.
So this L, by definition,
is invariant under,
in addition to the
usual translation
rotation symmetries, et cetera,
has also internal symmetry--
under UN, global symmetry.
OK.
So say phi x goes to
U, phi x u dagger,
for any u, any
constant, is u N matrix.
So this series is
invariant under-- so this
is obvious from here,
because of this trace,
so this is invariant under this.
Hm?
So let me just
make some remarks.
Before we proceed to talk about
the features of this series,
let me just make
some quick remarks.
Zero.
This is a theory of N
squared scalar field.
OK.
So if this is intuitive
to you, then this just
means you have many, many
fields coupled together
in some specific way.
And also we don't have to
consider Hermitian matrices.
To consider Hermitian
matrices just for simplicity,
one can also consider
other types of matrices.
For example, real
symmetric matrices.
So it's real symmetrical,
anti-symmetric matrices.
So in those cases, if you
consider, say, real matrices,
then symmetric or anti-symmetric
matrices, in that case,
this global symmetry becomes
s o N, rather than u n.
So in here, this u
is a global symmetry.
This u has become and
cannot depend on x.
You see from here, it
But you can also-- can
also introduce gauge fields
to make this u n symmetry local.
So I will not do it
now, but this will be
important a little bit later.
So later, we will indeed make
it into a local gauge symmetry.
But for now, let we just
consider this simple example.
Because I don't want to
introduce too many fields,
et cetera.
So any questions regarding
the setup of this theory?
AUDIENCE: Yes, can you explain
that last point one more time?
What do you mean
the-- if you-- how
does introducing gauge fields
make the symmetry local?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
You have to take
8324 to know that.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: But the simple
way to explain it--
yeah, there's no simple
way to explain it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'll draw
the fields, I guess.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah, just say-- let me
just explain the statement.
If you introduce
some gauge fields,
then you can make this u to be
some arbitrary function of x,
rather than a constant.
So that's the
statement of a local.
AUDIENCE: That's fine.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Just so I can
generalize this theory,
so that this symmetry
becomes local--
AUDIENCE: Ah.
I see.
HONG LIU: Becomes a
symmetry so that u
can have arbitrary x
dependence-- can have
arbitrary spacetime dependence.
So right now, u
must be a constant.
Any other questions?
Good.
OK.
So now, let's just try to
do perturbation theory.
Think g squared small.
Try to do perturbation theory.
OK.
So the first thing
you do-- of course,
you should write down
the Feynman rules.
Say, first thing, you have
to look at the propagator.
Look at the propagator.
So you can, essentially-- you
are all field theory experts,
so just by looking
at that Lagrangian,
then you can immediately
write down this propagator.
We can just write
down x minus y.
So whatever propagator--
whatever spacetime dependence,
let me just call it x minus y.
But also there's the
nontrivial index structure.
First there's also g squared.
OK.
Because there's a
prefactor 1/g squared.
So when you invert
the connection,
there's a g squared.
But the index structure
is at a b, b a.
So that a must contract with
d and b must be the same as c.
So that means we have
delta a d and delta b c.
OK.
Because in the Lagrangian,
only those fields are paired.
So the propagator must
have this structure.
So similarly, we
can write down the--
so there is a four particle
interaction vertex.
So each particle has two
index, so this is a b,
c d, e f, oh yeah, right, sorry.
Let me add one more.
And then I can denote
this diagramatically just
as a b c d, OK.
Just denote this diagramatically
as the propagator,
which is wavy line a b c d.
OK.
And now, also, we have this
quartic interaction vertices,
which is involving four fields.
So each field has two index,
because a b, so a b c d, f g h.
But this is another
arbitrary interaction
they have contracted.
In the interaction, they
contract in a specific way.
So you get 1/g squared
because of [INAUDIBLE] factor
g squared.
And then you have
delta b c, delta
d e, delta f g, delta h a.
OK, because they have
to be contracted.
Better to write it as
a b, this way. a b.
OK.
So a b, b contracted with
c, d contracted with e, e
contracted with g, h contracted
with a, so this gives you
a matrix product.
So just like that, OK.
AUDIENCE: So it doesn't
propagate or anything.
It just changes a and b.
HONG LIU: Hm?
a b
AUDIENCE: --contracted with d.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Let me just [INAUDIBLE] d c.
That's right.
OK.
So this is a Feynman rule.
So now you can
start calculating.
So if you have calculated
this for a while,
then you find this is
a little bit tedious.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: With all these
indices, it's quite annoying.
But t' Hooft was a smart fellow.
He said, let me find a way
so that I don't have to keep
track of all these indices.
Then he invented
a very nice way.
So this is called
double line notation.
So first, this
propagator a b c d,
since that a is
contracted with c, c
is contracted with b
separately, he said,
let's just write it
as a double line.
But since there's a difference
between the upper the lower
indices, so let's define a
direction for this double line.
So let's define the direction
to go from the upper index
to the lower index.
Then you will have a b,
then you have d, then c b.
Because for c, is upper to
lower index, to go from c d.
So now you don't have to worry
about this thing anymore,
because it's automatically
taken care of by this notation.
Similarly, this one is
also automatically taken
care of because each one, if you
replace it, by the double line
notation, then you
just make it a,
b, then b is equal to c, b equal
to it here, c equal to c, d
equal to d, and a to a.
And then we have g squared,
here you have g squared.
So once you do all the
double line notation-- so
let me also draw the arrow--
once you have double line
notation, then all of
those annoying deltas,
they're automatically
taken care of.
AUDIENCE: On the left,
that side, [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: c is on the top of d.
HONG LIU: Sorry, which one?
AUDIENCE: That [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Here?
AUDIENCE: Yes, c is on the top.
HONG LIU: That--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, if
we write [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Oh.
OK.
delta b c.
That's right.
b c.
Good.
So now let us give you some
examples of using this diagram
to calculate things.
And also try to calculate
the independents.
Because eventually we want
to take a large N limit.
OK.
So we want to keep track
of the independents.
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: The four
point coupling?
Does that come from the
commutator in the f [INAUDIBLE]
in the gauge theory?
HONG LIU: No, I just
wrote it down by myself.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it's
an additional thing.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: It's actually-- yeah.
Just arbitrary field theory.
Just an example.
OK.
So now let's start calculating.
You already have
the Feynman rule.
What are you waiting for?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: Haha.
So let's just calculate.
So the first thing, let's
look at the vacuum energy.
So that's the first
thing to calculate.
So what's the vacuum energy?
The vacuum energy
is all the diagrams.
It's a summation of all of
the diagrams without external
[INAUDIBLE].
OK.
So the simplest diagram
is just with one vertex.
OK.
So this is the simplest diagram.
But now, so if you
do lambda 5 4 theory,
then that will be
the end of the story.
OK.
You just contract them.
But now, the matrix, because
we have contracting matrices,
so this is like contracting
to four matrices.
When you're contracting
matrices-- but matrices
don't commute.
So actually there's
a difference.
So you should convince
yourself there's
a difference which
I actually connect
these two from which I connect
these two and these two.
OK.
Because this corresponding to I
connect with neighboring ones.
And this one I connect
with diagonal ones.
And the order actually matters.
The order actually matters.
Because matrices don't commute.
So if I call this a and the
b, and a not equal to b.
Because the matrices
don't commute.
So now let's do the N counting.
So to do the N counting
is actually much simpler
if we use the double
line notation.
So let's now use the
double line notation.
Because all these N, so when
you do the contractions,
you have all these indices, you
sum all those indices-- when
you sum all those indices, you
will get some factors of N.
So that's how N will
come into this theory.
But double line notation makes
the constraint all manifest,
so the contraction
will be automatic.
You don't have to worry
about all those deltas.
So let's just do that.
Let's draw this
four point vertex.
For this one, we just
contract the neighboring ones.
For this one, we
do the same thing.
We contract the
neighboring ones.
Yeah.
I did not draw very well.
Let me--
OK.
So this one should be
contracted with this one.
This one should be
contracted with that one.
And this one contract with
this one, and this one
is contracted there.
OK.
There's some intersection.
So now let's come to the end.
So now here is the key.
Each loop corresponding
to a contracted indices.
So for example, in here,
this is already a and a.
And then if you contract these
two, then you sum over this a
when you calculate
the propagator.
And then that gives
you a factor of n.
So each contract, each
closed loop, essentially
gives you a factor of n.
Just because you
contract-- yeah.
So there are three loops here.
Three contracted loops.
So this gives you n cubed.
And if you look at the
g squared dependence,
so you have two
propagators here.
You have two propagators.
Each propagator gives
you a g squared.
Then you have one vertex.
Each vertex gives you 1/g
squared, so you have g squared.
OK.
So now let's look at this one.
This one, this says
follow this line-- oh, you
should also draw the
arrow, because the arrow
should follow.
I did not draw the arrow,
but arrows should all follow.
The arrow should be consistent.
Similarly, here.
So here, if you go
around, you find
there is only a single
contracted line.
So this, only a factor of n.
Of course, g squared
dependency is the same.
So you have g squared.
So now you already
see the difference
between these two diagrams.
One is proportionate to n, one
is proportionate to n cubed.
So a, diagram a, can be drawn
on the plane-- we are drawing it
on the plane without
crossing lines,
so we call it a planar diagram.
And b cannot be drawn on the
plane without crossing lines,
so we call it a
non-planar diagram.
So let's do one more step.
So let's do one more diagram.
So next order, you just get
two, next order [INAUDIBLE]
diagram without [INAUDIBLE]
you have two vertices.
OK.
So you can connect this way.
So this is one diagram.
You can also have a
non-planar diagram-- yeah,
let me just draw the
straight line, rather than
the wavy line, just
to save trouble.
You can, for example,
you can draw like this,
so this is a non-planar diagram.
So now I'll give you an
exercise today when you go home.
Turn those into
double line diagrams.
Then you should find
yourself that this
is n to the power of 4.
Yeah.
Maybe I should do this.
Yeah, let me do
this one for you.
So let me just do this
one quickly for you.
But I will not draw the
arrows, just to save time.
So this one, you count
how many contracted lines?
One, two, three, four, so
this gives you n to the 4th
for the area.
And this I will not do it now.
You do it yourself.
So, also, if you count
the g dependents,
this gives you g
to the power of 4.
And this gives you n
squared, g to the power of 4.
Is it g to the power of 4?
Maybe I'm counting wrong.
One, two, three, four.
Four propagators is g squared.
Yeah. g to the power of 4.
Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So in general, the
more-- the more crossings,
would that decrease n?
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's right.
OK.
So now you can just continue.
With three vertices, with
four vertices, et cetera.
But of course, the smart fellows
will not stop, and they ask,
can I find some
rules in doing this?
So, how do you get the
general n counting?
And whether that's the old
planar diagram with the same,
or does one need to
classify them further?
OK.
So these are the
obvious questions.
So let me just tell
you some observations.
Then we are closed for today.
Then we will close for today.
So the first observation.
So just from those examples, let
me just draw some observations.
Observation one-- so this
one requires a little bit
of ingenuity.
It says, even a and
b-- so this a and b--
they cannot be
drawn on the plane.
They cannot be drawn on the
plane without crossing lines.
But a and b can be drawn on a
torus without crossing lines.
So now let me show it to you.
So what is a torus?
So we can draw a torus on
the plane, like follows,
so we draw a square.
Then we identify this
side with that side.
Identify this side
with that side.
Then this gives us a torus.
OK.
Because when you do that,
that give you cylinder.
And then you do that again,
and it gives you a torus.
But on the plane, just
simple identification.
So let's try to
see this diagram.
Now let me show this diagram
can be drawn on the torus
without crossing, because
the vertex is like this.
We want to contract with this
guy with that guy, and that guy
with that guy, right?
Not labeling lines.
But now I can just go up.
Now this is
identified with here,
then I can come back here.
Can go here, come back here.
So this is contracted.
And I don't have to cross lines.
Yes?
Good.
Similarly, let me do that one.
Yeah, that one, maybe I
will let you do yourself.
Yeah, do the-- so this a--
no, this is not a and b.
This is b and d.
Let me call this-- b, this
is-- let me call it c and d.
So a and c are
planar diagrams and b
and d are non-planar diagrams.
OK.
So this is b.
So try to do it yourself, the d.
So you essentially
you have two vertex.
How to make that
non-planar diagram
to be planar on this torus
when you identify here
with there, and
there with there?
OK.
So this observation one.
Actually, let me
just do it for you.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: So we
connect because I
need to do-- because it's
better I have this example
to make my second point.
So now I need to connect
this to that guy,
but I can do it by going up.
I can-- this guy can go here.
And then go there.
Similar thing, OK.
And then this is-- I can connect
them without crossing lines.
So this is observation one.
So now, observation two, again,
is a little bit ingenious,
but maybe slightly easier if
you have done it long enough.
For all the a to d, the
Fourier rule is true.
The power of n is equal
to number of faces.
So this one, we call-- so even
though they cannot be crossed,
they cross nice on the plane,
but we can actually straighten
them out on the torus.
OK.
So here we can straighten
them out on the torus.
So the second [INAUDIBLE]
is a power of n,
it's the number of
faces in each diagram.
After we straighten it out.
OK.
First, let's look
at this diagram.
This is a planar diagram.
So there's one face.
There's two faces.
And then there's a face outside,
because there's a whole plane.
So there's three faces.
So this is n cubed.
And the b, on the torus,
there's only one face,
because each region is
connected to each other.
OK.
So there's only one face.
You see the power n.
So now you see you had one
face, you have two faces,
we have three faces,
we have four faces,
so this is n to the power of 4.
And for this one, you have one
face corresponding to here.
And then you easily
convince yourself everything
outside this region,
they're connected
through the identification,
so you get n squared.
OK.
Then n squared.
So there's two observations.
So let me stop here.
And then, from here, you can
figure out the general rules
for everything.
[APPLAUSE]